et je vous le disais en titre les
Yvelines ont été victimes de fortes
précipitations dans la nuit de lundi à
mardi les conséquences sont lourdes une
dizaine de routes départementale a été
fermé et des coupures électriques
locales ont été enregistrées sur le
réseau SNCF les lignes rouillé éperernom
et rouillé charart étaient fermé dans la
matinée et même en début d'après-midi
suite à la chute d'arbres sur les voies
et la ligne de train de saint-cir a
connu des ralentissements dans les
Yveline à Plaisir la ville a été
particulièrement touchée par ses
intempéries le centre-ville a été
partiellement inondé comme vous vous
pouvez le voir sur ces images les
secteurs submergés par les eaux
concernent le château de la ville et le
quartier du stade des peupliers on
écoute les réaction des habitants de la
commune ils étaient au micro de Michel
el
midorou pour le moment j'ai juste sorti
la voiture du parking en sous-sol et je
l'ai mis sur le parking de l'église ça
fait ça fait 10 ans et moi c'est la
première fois que je vois ça j'avais pas
vu ça avant j'habitais j'ai toujours
habité dans la région et j'ai pas eu de
de soucis comme ça mon jardin est
inondé je peux rien faire j'ai mis des
plantations
tout est mort tout tout est inondé
toutes les plantations qu'on a mis dans
le jardin c'est fissu
voilà on fait
avec en 24 heur il est tombé 56 mm d'eau
sur trappe alors que la normale pour le
mois de mai est de 63,9 mm la vigilance
orange est levée depuis ce midi mais
dans les jours à venir le temps devrait
être moins qu'appréci rassurez-vous